A quick warning-- there are curse words that are un-beeped in today's episode of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
先作一个简短的警告——今天这期节目中包含未消音的脏话。如果您更喜欢消音版本，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上找到。
In a crisis, we learn new things about the people we love. Saw this video online that this nurse, Elise Barrett, in Seattle made for her husband. She works in a cancer clinic but figured she'd be called to work in an ICU once things heated up there with COVID-19 cases, and she had some things she wanted to say to him.
在危机时刻，我们对所爱之人会有新的了解。我曾在网上看到这段视频，是西雅图的一位护士伊莉丝·巴雷特（Elise Barrett）为她丈夫录制的。她在一家癌症诊所工作，但预感到随着新冠肺炎病例激增，她会被调到重症监护室（ICU）支援。她有一些话想对丈夫说。
Hey, Bubber. I wanted to make this video for you in case you find yourself in a really rough spot. I know you and I have had some conversations about what to do if, you know, I'm where I can't speak for myself, if I'm on a ventilator, if I'm super duper ill. You know I've seen a lot of awful stuff and awful deaths. And--
嘿，巴伯（Bubber）。我想给你录这段视频，以防你陷入非常艰难的境地。我知道我们讨论过，如果我无法自己表达意愿，如果我必须用呼吸机，如果我病得非常非常重，该怎么办。你知道我见过很多可怕的情况和悲惨的死亡。而且——
She was an ICU nurse for nearly 10 years. And she instructs him, if she's on a ventilator, with no awareness or ability to interact and no chance to wake up again, let her die. Or another possibility--
她做了近10年的重症监护室护士。她嘱咐丈夫，如果她需要呼吸机，且已经丧失意识或互动能力，也没有苏醒的可能，就让她离开。还有另一种可能——
If at some point I'm coding, and I'm coding over and over, they'll be able to tell you. Don't-- don't make them code me over and over. If I've had a protracted hypoxic code, don't make them keep working me. If they're thinking that there's going to be massive brain damage secondary to generalized hypoxia, they'll tell you, there's white on the CAT scan. There's swelling in the brain, generalized. People don't come back from that. And there's not really a lot of hope left at that point of getting me back. So at that point, you got to let me go.
如果到了某个时刻我需要抢救，而且需要反复抢救，医生会告诉你的。别——别让他们反复折腾我。如果我已经经历了长时间的缺氧性抢救，别让他们继续施救。如果他们认为由于全身性缺氧会导致严重的脑损伤，他们会告诉你，CT扫描显示大脑有白色影像。大脑会有广泛肿胀，人是无法从那种状态恢复的。到那个时候，剩下的希望微乎其微。所以在那时，你必须放手让我走。
She's entirely business-like about this-- medical professional running through the things that she needs him to now. Yes, they talked about this before, but now she has some details, some gaps to fill in. And she ticks through the possibilities of what could happen to her. If she's on a ventilator and starts to recover, she warns her husband not to get too hopeful, because it's not unusual for people to turn a corner and get worse again.
她谈起这些时非常公事公办——这位医学专业人士逐一梳理了她现在需要丈夫知道的事情。是的，他们之前讨论过，但现在她有了一些细节，需要填补空白。她列举了她可能遭遇的各种情况。如果她正在使用呼吸机并开始康复，她提醒丈夫不要抱太大希望，因为病人转好后再次恶化的情况并不少见。
If she dies, here's what she's thinking about a funeral. If she does recover and gets off the vent, he should know that it might be months of rehab before she'll be able to come home again. And one more thing she wants a partner to know--
如果她去世了，她对葬礼有一些想法。如果她康复并脱离了呼吸机，他应该知道，在那之后可能还需要数月的康复治疗，她才能回家。还有一件事，她想让伴侣知道——
You should be aware that when somebody is super duper sick, when they're proned, their face swells up. They look awful. If I'm sick enough to be mechanically ventilated, I'm going to look like shit, and I don't necessarily think you want to see that. It's OK for you not to visit me in the hospital. It's not going to be safe for you to visit me in the hospital.
你应该明白，当一个人病得非常非常重，并且需要俯卧通气时，脸会肿起来。样子会很难看。如果我病得严重到需要机械通气，我会看起来糟透了，我并不觉得你想看到那个样子。你没必要到医院来看我，这没关系。你到医院来看我也并不安全。
I would rather you stay home and take care of Kepler, and have this video and other stuff that I've left for you to make sure that your memories of me are not traumatic or scarring.
我宁愿你待在家里照顾开普勒（Kepler），留着这段视频和其他我留给你的东西，确保你对我的记忆不会是创伤性的或令人痛苦的。
Kepler is their two-year-old son.
开普勒是他们两岁的儿子。
I want you to be safe. I want you to take care of yourself. I love you more than anything else on earth, except maybe Kepler. Thank you for him. Thank you for giving me that beautiful boy and for giving me the life that we've had together. And I love you so much. I'll miss you. Bye, bye.
我希望你平安。我希望你照顾好自己。我爱你胜过世上的一切，也许除了开普勒。谢谢你给了我他。谢谢你给了我那个漂亮的男孩，谢谢你给了我们共度的生活。我非常爱你。我会想你的。再见，再见。
When you know somebody so well, what can you possibly say that's going to be news to them about who you are or what you think? I'm guessing nothing in this video was a huge surprise to this nurse's husband. But when there's a crisis, it's important to say certain things-- practical stuff, information and instructions. But also, there's feelings to share. We need to connect. It's not a moment for big revelations. You just want to tint the colors in the picture of you two a little bit, this way or that.
当你非常了解一个人时，还能说出什么关于你是谁或你在想什么的新鲜事呢？我猜这段视频中没有任何内容会让这位护士的丈夫感到特别惊讶。但在危机时刻，说出某些话很重要——实用的事项、信息和指令。但同时，也有情感需要分享。我们需要联结。这并不是进行重大披露的时刻。你只是想为你们俩的生活图景增添一点色彩。
My co-worker, Bim, has been having these daily conversations with her brother, Demola. He's been sick with COVID-19 for over a week now. And these conversations are totally different than that nurse's video. All the ways that nurse, Elise Barrett, is so direct, imagining every possible terrible outcome one by one and discussing it, Bim and Demola are not into that. I'm guessing, with no evidence at all here, that most of us are more like Bim and Demola. We'd rather sidestep the scariest possibilities for as long as possible.
我的同事比姆（Bim）最近每天都在和她的弟弟德莫拉（Demola）通电话。他感染新冠肺炎已经一周多了。这些对话和那位护士的视频截然不同。那位护士伊莉丝·巴雷特非常直接，逐一想象并讨论每一种可怕的结果，而比姆和德莫拉却不想谈这些。我凭空猜测，我们大多数人可能更像比姆和德莫拉。我们宁愿尽可能久地避开最可怕的可能性。
But in their daily talks, there's still new information passing between them than they usually share. She's in New York. Demola and the rest of her family are in London. He's four years younger.
但在他们每天的交谈中，仍然比平时分享了更多的新信息。她在纽约。德莫拉和她的其他家人都在伦敦。他比她小四岁。
He, perhaps, remains the most beautiful baby I have ever seen in my life, like aggressively so. My mom will tell you, oh yeah, Demola's the most beautiful of my babies. She makes no qualms about it. He was very beautiful.
他大概依然是我一生中见过的最漂亮的婴儿，那种漂亮的程度简直咄咄逼人。我妈妈会告诉你，噢没错，德莫拉是我所有孩子里最漂亮的。她对此直言不讳。他非常漂亮。他曾经是个非常漂亮的婴儿。
That's just rude to say to your other children.
对其他孩子那样说真的很失礼。
It's really rude. But Demola was beautiful. He was pretty. He was a pretty baby. He still has this little beauty spot right where Marilyn Monroe had hers.
确实很失礼。但德莫拉就是很漂亮。他很可爱。他是个漂亮的婴儿。他至今在玛丽莲·梦露长美人痣的地方也有一颗小美人痣。
Oh wow.
哇。
Yeah. And these lashes. And so when he was very little, my sister and I would put him on-- there was a short, exactly child level ironing board. It was more like a table. And we'd put him on there, and we would kiss him all over him until he would cry in protest.
是的。还有那睫毛。所以他很小的时候，我和我妹妹会把他放在——那里有一个正好适合孩子高度的熨衣板。它更像个桌子。我们会把他放在上面，吻遍他全身，直到他抗议地哭出来。
To hear Bim tell it, Demola's relationship with the sisters today is a faint echo of that. His older sister is more expressive with her feelings. Demola, a little bit apart, happy to be by himself, a separate island from the rest of them, keeping his own counsel, very quiet. Before he got sick, Bim would usually text him or talk to him on WhatsApp a couple of times a week. Lots of it was talk about TV shows and quoting Zapp Brannigan from Futurama to each other, and Bim mocking Demola whenever his team, Arsenal, loses.
按比姆的说法，德莫拉如今与姐妹们的关系只是那时的微弱回响。他的大姐在表达情感方面更外向。德莫拉则稍显疏离，乐于独处，像孤岛一样与家人隔开，守口如瓶，非常安静。在他生病前，比姆通常每周会给他发几次短信或在WhatsApp上聊天。大部分内容是讨论电视节目，互引《飞出个未来》里扎普·布拉尼根的台词，还有比姆在他钟爱的阿森纳队输球时嘲笑他。
But now that they're talking every day, and for the first time it's video chats, the dailiness of it gives everything a different feeling. And the subject matter is different too.
但现在他们每天通电话，而且第一次使用视频聊天，这种日常感赋予了一切不同的氛围。主题也不同了。
So I'm asking him, did you drink enough water today? What's your temperature? Did the cough go away? Is it a dry cough? So yeah, the questions, on the one hand, are very dry and basic. But on the other, I suppose because I've never asked them before, it feels extra special now to be asking very specifically, what's your temperature, and to be able to track his life in this way. The knowledge that it went from 37 degrees, and now it's 36 degrees. You know?
所以我问他，你今天喝够水了吗？体温多少？咳嗽好点了吗？是干咳吗？所以，一方面，这些问题非常干巴巴且基础。但另一方面，我想是因为我以前从未问过这些，现在能这样具体地询问“你的体温是多少”，并以此来追踪他的生命体征，感觉变得格外特别。知道体温从37度变成了36度，你知道吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
I mean in Celsius, obviously.
当然是指摄氏度。
Yeah.
嗯。
It just feels really oddly intimate that I know the temperature of his body across an ocean.
我能跨越海洋知道他的体温，这感觉非常奇特且亲密。
Even though the question seems really bland on the surface-- you know, what's your temperature? It's a way of asking-- and it's a way, I think, also of circumventing the elephant in the room, which is if he had a more serious case of COVID-19, if his symptoms were more severe, if things were really dire-- you know, we just don't talk about it. So when I ask about his temperature, what I'm asking is-- it's like a shorthand. It's half language that we're using.
尽管表面上这个问题看起来非常平淡——你知道，“你体温多少？”——但这是一种询问的方式——我认为这也是一种绕过那个显而易见的问题（大象）的方式，那就是如果他的新冠病情更严重，如果症状更严重，如果情况真的很危急——你知道，我们只是不谈论它。所以当我问他的体温时，我的意思其实是——这就像一种简写。这是我们正在使用的另一种语言。
There's a Yoruba saying my mom often says, which is, speaking from underneath your tongue. And in a way, I feel like I am speaking from underneath my tongue to ask a really serious question but in the most bland language, which is, oh, are you drinking water? What was the headache like? It's asking these very basic questions that are basically pushing back my fear of what this could have been. That's terrifying to me.
约鲁巴语里有一句我妈妈常说的话，就是“从舌头底下说话”。某种程度上，我觉得我就是在从舌头底下说话，问一个极其严肃的问题，却用了最平淡的语言，比如“噢，你在喝水吗？”“头痛怎么样？”询问这些非常基本的问题，其实是在推开我对这件事可能演变结果的恐惧。那对我来说太可怕了。
Because the thing underneath it that you're not saying is--
因为你没说出口的潜台词是——
The thing I'm-- the thing I'm saying-- I feel like I'm screaming it-- is please don't die. I don't want you to die.
我正在说——我觉得我简直在尖叫——是“求你别死”。我不想要你死。
So it sounds like she's learning some new information about this person she knows so well in these daily conversations. But she's seeing such a different side of him. Normally, he's so stoic, she says. But now he's way more vulnerable and way more open to everybody in the family calling him all the time and asking him questions.
听起来她在这些日常谈话中了解到了关于她非常熟悉的人的一些新信息。但她看到了他截然不同的一面。她说，通常他非常坚忍。但现在他变得脆弱多了，对家里所有人打来电话问候他也更加开放了。
I think he wants to be fussed over, in this at least, a little bit.
我觉得他至少在这种情况下，是希望被嘘寒问暖的。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I think he likes it a little bit. And obviously, it will get more annoying as he gets better and stronger again. But for now, he's basically a baby on an ironing table, and we're going to kiss him.
我觉得他有点享受。当然，等他康复且变得更强壮时，这会变得更烦人。但目前，他基本就像熨衣板上的婴儿，我们正准备去吻他。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, moments when we fill in the gaps and see parts of somebody we have not seen before, but we learn it can be a kind of subtle shading around the edges. Though, in all of our stories today, I have to say it is way bigger than that. It's people declaring, you thought you knew the truth, but no, no, no, you did not, not all of it. And the part that you didn't know changes everything.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在节目中，我们谈论那些填补空白的时刻，看到别人不为人知的一面。我们学到这可以是一种微妙的边缘阴影。虽然，在今天的所有故事中，我必须说，这比那要宏大得多。人们声明，你以为你知道真相，但并没有，不，不，你并不是全都知道。而你未曾了解的部分改变了一切。
Now, as Paul Harvey used to say, now you know the rest of the story. Stay with us.
正如保罗·哈维（Paul Harvey）过去常说的，现在你知道了故事的其余部分。请继续收听。
Act 1, I Can't be Your Hero, Baby.
第一幕：宝贝，我不能做你的英雄。
Certain stories get told over and over about undocumented immigrants in this country. And one of the big ones is about sacrifice-- about hardworking people who work long hours in restaurant kitchens, and farms, and other low paying jobs to support their families, grateful for the chance to be in the US. Or the DACA kids, who strive and want nothing more than college and the American dream. Karla Cornejo Villavicencio has heard lots of these stories and thought she could do better.
关于这个国家的无证移民，某些故事被反复讲述。其中一个重要主题是牺牲——关于那些在餐馆后厨、农场和其他低薪工作中辛勤工作，只为养家糊口，并感恩能留在美国的人们。或是那些追逐梦想，除了大学和美国梦别无所求的“追梦人”（DACA申请者）。卡拉·科内霍·维拉维森西奥（Karla Cornejo Villavicencio）听过很多这样的故事，并认为自己能写得更好。
Just a quick note about her essay-- there are very brief references in it to rape and suicide. Here she is.
关于她的文章有一个简短提示——其中有关于强奸和自杀的非常简短的提及。她来了。
When I was a senior in college, I wrote an anonymous essay for The Daily Beast about what they wanted to call my dirty little secret, that I was undocumented. This was in 2011, before DACA, and I was one of the first undocumented students to graduate Harvard. The essay got me some attention, and agents wrote me asking if I wanted to write a memoir.
我大学四年级时，为《每日野兽》写了一篇匿名文章，关于他们所称的我的“肮脏小秘密”——我是一名无证移民。那是2011年，在DACA政策出台之前，我是哈佛大学首批毕业的无证学生之一。那篇文章让我受到了一些关注，有经纪人写信问我是否想写一部回忆录。
I was angry. A memoir? I was 21. I wasn't fucking Barbra Streisand. I had been writing professionally since I was 15 but only about music. I wanted to be the guy in High Fidelity. And I didn't want my first book to be a rueful tale about being a sickly Victorian orphan with tuberculosis who didn't have a social security number, which is what the agents all wanted.
我很生气。回忆录？我才21岁。我又不是那个混蛋芭芭拉·史翠珊（Barbra Streisand）。我从15岁起就一直在进行专业写作，但只写音乐方面的。我想成为《失恋排行榜》（High Fidelity）里的那个家伙。我不想让我的第一本书变成一个关于患有肺结核、没有社会安全号的维多利亚时代孤儿的可悲故事，而那正是所有经纪人想要的。
The guy who eventually ended up becoming my agent respected that, did not find an interchangeable immigrant to publish a sad book, read everything I would write over the next seven years, and we kept in touch. I was the first person who wrote him on the morning of November 9th, 2016.
最终成为我经纪人的那个人尊重这一点，没有找一个随处可见的移民去出版一本悲伤的书，他读了我之后七年里写的每一篇东西，我们保持着联系。2016年11月9日早上，我是第一个给他写信的人。
That morning, I received a bunch of emails from people who are really freaked out about Trump winning. And the emails, essentially, were offers to hide me in their second houses in Vermont or stay in their basements. Shit, I told my partner, they're trying to Anne Frank me.
那天早上，我收到了一堆电子邮件，内容都是关于人们对特朗普获胜感到非常惊恐。这些邮件本质上都是提供在佛蒙特州的第二套房子里藏匿我，或者让我待在他们地下室里的邀请。我跟我伴侣说，这帮混蛋，他们想把我当安妮·弗兰克（Anne Frank）一样藏起来。
By this point, I had read lots of books about migrants. I hated a good number of these books. I couldn't see my family in them, because I saw my parents as more than laborers, as more than sufferers or dreamers. I thought I could write something better, and I thought I was the best person to do it. I was just crazy enough. Because if you're going to write about undocumented immigrants in America, tell the story, the full story, you have to be a little bit crazy. And you certainly can't be enamored by America, not still. That disqualifies you.
到这个时候，我已经读过很多关于移民的书。我很讨厌其中不少书。我在书中看不到我的家人，因为我眼中的父母不仅仅是劳动者，不仅仅是受难者或梦想家。我觉得我可以写出更好的东西，而且我认为我是写出它的最佳人选。我只是足够疯狂。因为如果你要写关于美国的无证移民，要讲述这个故事，完整的故事，你就必须有点疯狂。而且你肯定不能沉迷于美国，至少不能再沉迷了。那会让你失去资格。
I did not want to write anything inspirational. I wanted to write for everybody who wants to step away from the buzzwords in immigration-- the talking heads, the Dreamers in graduation caps and gowns-- and read about the people underground, not heroes, randoms, people. I wanted to write about my parents, and that's the story I'm going to tell here, the story of my parents.
我不想写任何励志的东西。我想为所有想要远离移民话题中流行词的人写作——远离那些谈话节目的嘉宾，远离穿着毕业礼服的“追梦人”——我想读关于地下世界的人们，不是英雄，不是随机的路人，而是真真切切的人。我想写我的父母，这就是我要在这里讲述的故事，我父母的故事。
If you ask my mother where she's from, she's 100% going to say, she's from the kingdom of god, because she does not like to say that she's from Ecuador, Ecuador being one of the few South American countries that has not especially outdone itself on the international stage. Magical realism basically skipped over it. And our military dictatorship never reached the mythical status of a Pinochet or a Videla. Plus, there are no world famous Ecuadorians to speak of other than the fool who housed Julian Assange at the embassy in London and Christina Aguilera's father, who she said was a domestic abuser.
如果你问我母亲她来自哪里，她百分之百会说她来自“上帝的国度”，因为她不喜欢说她来自厄瓜多尔，因为厄瓜多尔在国际舞台上表现并不出色。魔幻现实主义基本上跳过了它。我们的军事独裁统治从未达到皮诺切特或维德拉那种神话般的地位。此外，除了在伦敦大使馆收容朱利安·阿桑奇（Julian Assange）的那个傻瓜，以及克里斯蒂娜·阿奎莱拉（Christina Aguilera）说对其进行家暴的父亲，厄瓜多尔并没有什么举世闻名的人物。
If you ask my father where he's from, he will definitely say Ecuador, because he is sentimental about the country for reasons he's working out in therapy.
如果你问我父亲他来自哪里，他一定会说厄瓜多尔，因为他对这个国家有一种感伤的情怀，原因他正在心理治疗中梳理。
But if you push them, I mean really push them, they're both going to say they're from New York. If you ask them if they feel American, because you're a little narc who wants to prove your blood runs red, white, and blue, they're going to say no, we feel like New Yorkers. They've lived in New York since they left Ecuador in 1991.
但如果你逼问他们，我是说真的逼问，他们俩都会说他们来自纽约。如果你问他们是否感到自己是美国人，因为你是个有点讨厌想证明自己血统纯正的人，他们会说不，我们感觉自己是纽约人。自从1991年离开厄瓜多尔以来，他们一直住在纽约。
I don't know much about my parents' decision to choose New York, or even the United States, as a destination. It's not that I haven't asked them why they came to the United States. It's that the answer isn't as morally satisfying as most people's answers are-- a decapitated family member, famine. And I never pressed them for more details because I don't want to apply pressure on a bruise.
我不了解我父母选择纽约，甚至选择美国作为目的地的决定。不是我没问过他们为什么来美国。而是因为答案并不像大多数人的答案那样具有道德上的满足感——比如家里有人被斩首，或者饥荒。我从未追问细节，因为我不想往伤口上撒盐。
The story, as far as I know it, goes something like this. My parents had just gotten married, and their small auto body business was not doing well. The idea of coming to America to work for a year to make just enough money to pay off their debts came up, and it seemed like a good idea. They left me with my dad's family when I was a year and a half old. That's about as much as I know.
据我所知，故事大概是这样的。我父母刚结婚，他们的小型汽车维修生意做得不好。来美国工作一年，赚点钱还清债务的想法出现了，这似乎是个好主意。他们离开时把我留在了我父亲的家人身边，那时我才一岁半。这就是我所知道的全部。
My parents didn't come back after a year. They were barely making ends meet. When I was four years old, going to school in Ecuador, teachers began to comment on how gifted I was. My parents knew Ecuador was not the place for a gifted girl. The gender politics were too fucked up. And they wanted me to have all the educational opportunities they hadn't had. So that's when they brought me to New York. I was just shy of five when I stepped off the plane.
我父母一年后没有回来。他们勉强维持生计。我四岁时，在厄瓜多尔上学，老师们开始评论我有多么天才。我父母知道厄瓜多尔不是天才女孩待的地方。性别政治太糟糕了。他们希望我拥有他们未曾拥有过的所有教育机会。所以那时他们把我带到了纽约。我下飞机时还不到五岁。
White Americans love academically achieving minorities. And I learned quickly that the most alluring thing about me was that I was young and brown and a good student, the holy trinity. I went to a Catholic elementary school on a scholarship, and we lived in Queens. My mother stayed home, and my father drove a cab. This was back when East New York was still gang country, and he had to fold his body into a little origami swan and hide under his steering wheel during crossfires in the middle of the day.
美国白人喜欢在学业上取得成就的少数族裔。我很快了解到，我最吸引人的地方在于我年轻、肤色棕褐，而且是个好学生，这简直是三位一体。我靠奖学金上了一所天主教小学，我们住在皇后区。我母亲待在家里，我父亲开出租车。那是在东纽约还是黑帮横行的时候，他必须像个折纸天鹅一样把身体折起来，在光天化日之下的交火中躲在方向盘下面。
Then came September 11th, 2001. Here's how I remember the day my father started dying, not long after the twin towers fell. My father comes home from work, and I greet him in the doorway to give him a kiss hello. He walks slowly and comes toward my body at a strange angle a child could only interpret as a terrible fall. He collapses onto me to cry into my neck. I'm little, 12 or 13, but he does, he falls.
然后是2001年9月11日。这是我记忆中我父亲开始走向死亡的那一天，双子塔倒塌后不久。我父亲下班回家，我在门口迎接他，给他一个吻。他走得很慢，以一种孩子只能理解为“可怕摔倒”的奇怪角度向我走来。他倒在我身上，在我的脖子里哭泣。我那时还小，12或13岁，但他确实，他摔倒了。
The letter says in English something about the DMV suspending driver's licenses for undocumented immigrants. It was part of an attempt to strengthen security measures after 9/11. My father had just lost his job as a taxi driver. He had also lost his state ID. Over the next 20 years, he'd lose many more things, but let's put a little blue thumb tack on this memory map, the first place in Hell we visited.
那封信是用英文写的，大概是说车管所暂停了无证移民的驾照。这是9/11后加强安全措施的一部分。我父亲刚丢了出租车司机的工作。他也失去了州身份证。在接下来的20年里，他还会失去更多东西，但让我们在这个记忆地图上贴一个蓝色图钉，这是我们造访过的地狱的第一站。
September 11th changed the immigration landscaper forever. ICE was the creation of 9/11 paranoia. It changed my father, too. It was hard to see him fall, because he was the most powerful person I knew. He was a difficult man, and I was a difficult child. I was polite and craved approval from authority figures, but I was also dark and precocious. Not precocious in the, we live in Tribeca, and my kid is a born artist, kind of way. More like, my immigrant third grader is reading Hemingway but is secretly drinking Listerine and toothpaste until she throws up because she wants it to kill her, kind of way.
9/11永远改变了移民的格局。移民局（ICE）是9/11偏执的产物。它也改变了我父亲。看到他摔倒很难受，因为他是我认识的最强大的人。他是一个很难相处的人，我是一个很难相处的孩子。我很有礼貌，渴望权威人物的认可，但我同时也很阴暗、早熟。不是那种住在翠贝卡（Tribeca），孩子天生就是艺术家的那种早熟。更像是那种——我的移民三年级学生在读海明威，但却偷偷喝李施德林漱口水和吃牙膏直到呕吐，因为她想让这些东西杀了她——的那种早熟。
Only years later would I realized how real my suicidal impulses were. That was too damn young, I'd think, lying down in the dark at my doctor's office with an IV of ketamine hooked up to my arm, hoping to extinguish the suicidality that began when I was five and lay crayons around the perimeter of my bed so I'd know in the morning if I'd been secretly raped at night. I'd know because the crayons would be broken.
只有在多年后，我才意识到我的自杀冲动有多么真实。我那时心想，太该死地年轻了，躺在医生办公室黑暗中，手臂上挂着氯胺酮静脉注射液，希望能熄灭那种从五岁开始就产生的自杀念头，那时我会在床边铺满蜡笔，这样我就能知道早上起来自己是否在夜里被秘密强奸了。我会知道，因为蜡笔会被折断。
My father read parenting books that explained how to raise troubled children. But those children were never straight-A students who were soft-spoken and loved teachers. It confused him, and the dissonance made him angry at me. He saw me as different from other children in a way that troubled him, and he fumbled in the dark to help me with what he couldn't name.
我父亲读过解释如何抚养问题儿童的育儿书。但那些孩子从来不是品学兼优、说话轻声细语且讨老师喜欢的学生。这让他感到困惑，这种不一致让他对我感到愤怒。他觉得我和其他孩子不同，这让他很不安，他在黑暗中摸索着试图帮我解决他无法命名的问题。
When I was off from school for any kind of break, my father would plan out my day in half hour increments, scheduling everything from bath time, to TV shows, to coloring time, to math drills, to time to play with dolls, and even bathroom breaks. He called it my schedule, and he hand wrote it on graph paper in different colored inks and taped it to my desk. When I became overwhelmed with panic, crying hysterically, he would send me to take a cold shower or take me out on a jog around the neighborhood.
每当学校放假，我父亲都会以半小时为单位规划我的一天，安排从洗澡时间、看电视、涂色时间、数学练习、玩偶时间，甚至上厕所的时间。他称之为“我的日程表”，用不同颜色的墨水在方格纸上手写出来，并贴在我的桌子上。当我因恐慌而歇斯底里哭泣时，他会送我去洗冷水澡，或者带我去社区慢跑。
He'd set aside a magazine or a newspaper articles for me to translate. He could not review the fidelity of the translation, but he judged my penmanship. I didn't know what would have happened to me if I had not been kept away from my own thoughts for so many years. My father kept me alive.
他会留出杂志或报纸文章让我翻译。他无法审核翻译的准确性，但他会评价我的字迹。我不知道如果这么多年来没有被隔离在自己的思绪之外，我会变成什么样。我父亲让我活了下来。
After my father lost his job as a taxi driver, he found a job as a delivery man at a restaurant down in the Financial District. In the mornings, he would deliver breakfast to offices-- a raisin bagel with cream cheese and a coffee with hazelnut creamer, orange juice and a banana, a granola bar and chocolate milk. There was no delivery minimum, so my father delivered it all. Because the deliveries were so small, sometimes he didn't get a tip. Sometimes he was told to keep the change, a quarter. Sometimes he was tipped in pennies. He had to say, thank you, sir, thank you, ma'am.
在丢了出租车司机的工作后，我父亲在金融区的一家餐馆找了一份送餐的工作。每天早上，他都会把早餐送到办公室——一个涂奶油芝士的葡萄干贝果，一杯加榛子奶油的咖啡，橙汁和香蕉，燕麦棒和巧克力牛奶。没有最低送餐额，所以我父亲什么都送。因为订单太小，有时他拿不到小费。有时他被告知“不用找零了”，那是25美分。有时小费是一堆硬币。他必须说：“谢谢你，先生；谢谢你，女士。”
Sometimes he was given a $20 tip for a $5.00 breakfast. He always told us about those tips. They were usually from Puerto Rican receptionists who talked to him in Spanish and asked to see photos of me. When he came home was one of those tips, it was like having my dad back from the dead. He would dance to no music, and he'd make jokes, and he'd come out of his shower looking like a teenager.
有时他会因为一份5美元的早餐收到20美元的小费。他总是跟我们提起那些小费。它们通常来自那些用西班牙语跟他交谈、要求看我照片的波多黎各前台接待员。每当他带着那样的小费回家时，就像我父亲死而复生了一样。他会在没有音乐的情况下跳舞，讲笑话，走出浴室时看起来像个青少年。
My father didn't use a bike. He made all his deliveries on foot. He speed walked while carrying bags of food to offices on Wall Street. The plastic handles of the bags would twist and cut into his fingers, and he developed large calluses on both his hands. His polyester pants rubbed up against his calves so much that he lost all the hair on his legs.
我父亲不用自行车。他所有的配送都是步行完成的。他带着装满食物的袋子在华尔街的办公室间竞走。塑料袋手柄扭曲并切入他的手指，他的双手长出了巨大的老茧。他的涤纶裤子与小腿摩擦得太厉害，以至于他腿上的毛都磨光了。
He went through many pairs of inexpensive black rubber shoes. My mother massaged his feet at night. My dad's feet are small and fat, like mine, so you can't tell when they're swollen. After a few years, my dad's feet would hurt so much that he walked like he was on hot coals, sometimes leaning on me to move from the couch to the bed. Aye, yai, yai, yai, yai, he'd say, as he limped, like a mariachi.
他穿坏了许多双便宜的黑色橡胶鞋。我母亲晚上会为他按摩双脚。我父亲的脚又小又胖，和我的一样，所以你看不出什么时候肿了。几年后，我父亲的双脚疼得厉害，走起路来像走在热煤上，有时还得靠我扶着才能从沙发走到床边。“哎呀呀呀呀，”他边走边哀叹，像个流浪乐手（mariachi）。
When I was 15, the owner of the restaurant where my father worked hired a new manager to oversee the delivery men, who were all immigrants. The guy was Puerto Rican, an American citizen, and became immediately abusive, threatening to call ICE on them, yelling at them, getting up in their faces. My father fell into a bit of a depression.
我15岁那年，我父亲工作的餐馆老板雇了一位新经理来监管送餐人员，他们都是移民。那家伙是波多黎各人，美国公民，立即开始虐待他们，威胁要向移民局告发他们，对他们大吼大叫，凑到他们脸上挑衅。我父亲陷入了抑郁。
I had just watched All the President's Men. I put on my best posh accent, dialed *69 to block my number, and called the restaurant. I asked to speak to the owner. I said I was a beat reporter for a big city newspaper and had just received a tip from a customer about overhearing racist abuse in the kitchen. And did he have a comment? The owner said he'd handle it and asked me not to write the story. I don't know, man, I said, it's a pretty good story. In the end, the manager was fired, and the cloud over my father lifted.
我刚看了《总统班底》（All the President's Men）。我用上我最好的时髦口音，拨打*69屏蔽了我的号码，给餐馆打了电话。我要求和老板通话。我说我是大城市报纸的调查记者，刚收到客户提供的关于在后厨听到种族主义辱骂的举报。他有评论吗？老板说他会处理，并要求我不要发表这个故事。我说，我不确定，伙计，这是个相当不错的故事。最终，经理被解雇了，笼罩在我父亲头上的阴云散去了。
My father was furious when I told him what I did. But not for a minute in the 15 years since have I felt that what I did was unethical. Nor have I felt guilty for having a man fired. I'd do it again, but my accent would be better.
当我告诉父亲我所做的事时，他气疯了。但在过去的15年里，我从未有一分钟觉得我所做的是不道德的。我也从未为让一个人失业感到内疚。我会再做一次，但我会把口音练得更好。
I went to a small public high school in Times Square, where around 80% of the student body was at or below the poverty line. We were mostly all black or Latinx. I was a high achiever. I wanted to go to the University of Chicago because I found the unofficial motto, where fun goes to die, appealing. But there is no beating Harvard. That name. I needed the name to keep my parents safe.
我就读于时代广场的一所小型公立高中，那里约80%的学生处于贫困线或以下。我们大部分是黑人或拉丁裔。我是个高材生。我想去芝加哥大学，因为我发现他们非官方的校训“欢乐去死之地”很有吸引力。但没有任何学校能胜过哈佛。那个名字。我需要这个名字来保护我的父母。
Harvard, at the time, did not know how to deal with undocumented students. When I was there, a very successful Wall Street man who knew me from an educational NGO we both belonged to-- he as a supporter, me as a supported-- learned I was undocumented and could not legally hold a work-study job. So every semester, he wrote me a modest check. In the notes section, and he cheekily wrote, beer money.
当时的哈佛不知道如何处理无证学生。我在那里时，一位从我们共同所属的教育非政府组织中认识我的华尔街成功人士——他是支持者，我是被支持者——得知我是无证移民，在法律上不能持有勤工俭学的职位。所以每个学期，他都会写给我一张数额不大的支票。在备注栏里，他调皮地写着“啤酒钱”。
I wrote him regular emails about my life at Harvard and my budding success as a published writer. He was always appropriate and boundaried. I had read obsessively about artists since I was a kid and considered myself an artist since I was a kid, so I didn't feel weird about older, wealthy, white people giving me money in exchange for grades or writing. It was patronage. They were Gertrude Stein, and I was a young Hemingway. I was van Gogh, crazy and broken. I truly did not have any racial anxieties about this, thank god. That kind of thing could really fuck a kid up.
我会定期给他发邮件，讲述我在哈佛的生活以及我作为出版作家不断增长的成就。他总是表现得非常得体，保持界限。我从小就痴迷于阅读关于艺术家的书，并且从小就认为自己是一名艺术家，所以对于年长、富有、白人给我钱作为成绩或写作的回报，我并不觉得奇怪。这是资助。他们是格特鲁德·斯泰因（Gertrude Stein），而我是年轻的海明威。我是梵高，疯狂而破碎。感谢上帝，我在这方面真的没有任何种族焦虑。那种事情真的会毁掉一个孩子。
Different therapists throughout the years have tried to get me to confess to cultural shock about arriving to Harvard as a poor, undocumented freshman. But the truth is there was none. I've always had a really wonderful sense of self-esteem thanks to my mother, who is a tiny bit of a narcissist and has delusions of royalty, and because of my mental illness, which comes with delusions of grandeur of its own. So I kind of felt like it was my birthright. That probably makes a lot of people very mad.
多年来，不同的治疗师试图让我承认作为一名贫困的、无证的大一新生进入哈佛所带来的文化冲击。但事实是，根本没有。多亏了我那有点自恋且有皇室幻想的母亲，以及我那自带宏大幻觉的精神疾病，我一直有着非常棒的自尊心。所以我觉得这简直是我的天生权利。那可能会让很多人非常生气。
As I began to receive my diagnoses and misdiagnoses throughout my 20s-- depression, anxiety, OCD, bipolar disorder, borderline personality disorder, complex trauma-- I didn't feel anything other than affinity with writers I loved, people like Emily Dickinson, Sylvia Plath, Anne Sexton, and Robert Lowell. It made sense to me that I had my own demons. Of course I did.
当我在20多岁时开始收到我的诊断和误诊——抑郁症、焦虑症、强迫症、双相情感障碍、边缘性人格障碍、复杂创伤——我对自己拥有的恶魔感到很自然。我当然有。
I've always been super casual when people ask me about my parents having left me in Ecuador. That's a bravado I'd like to keep on the official record. But sometimes I think about it. I haven't talked with my parents about their having left me in Ecuador when I was a year and a half old. Sometimes I do adorable things, like take pictures of myself chugging vodka bottles or pretending to down the contents of a pill bottle, and send them to my mother with the caption, because you abandoned me.
当人们问起我父母把我留在厄瓜多尔的事时，我总是表现得非常随意。这是我愿意保持在官方记录上的硬汉形象。但有时我会去想它。我没有和我父母谈过他们在我一岁半时把我留在厄瓜多尔的事。有时我会做些可爱的举动，比如拍下自己猛灌伏特加瓶的照片，或者假装吞下药瓶里的药丸，并发给我母亲，附上说明：“因为你抛弃了我。”
When I am away from my partner and dog for a few days for work, and it's hard, I wonder how my parents were able to do it for three years. I don't blame either of them for it. I never have. What I'm describing to you is dirt extracted from a very tight pore. I don't feel anything about being left on the day to day, but I am told by mental health experts that it has affected me.
当我因为工作离开伴侣和狗几天，感到困难时，我不知道我父母当年是怎么坚持了三年的。我没有责怪他们中的任何一个。从来没有。我向你们描述的是从一个非常紧致的毛孔中提取出来的污垢。我对被留在那里的日常没什么感觉，但心理健康专家告诉我，这已经影响了我。
And I fought that conclusion. I denied it. I wanted to be a genius. I wanted my mental illnesses to be purely biological. I wanted to have been born wild and crazy and weird and brilliant, writing math equations in chalk on a window. Instead, therapist after therapist told me I had attachment issues and that my mental illnesses were related to my childhood. I left those therapists, ghosted them.
我反抗过这个结论。我否认了它。我想成为天才。我希望我的精神疾病是纯粹生物性的。我希望我是天生狂野、疯狂、怪异且聪明，在窗户上用粉笔写数学方程式。相反，一个又一个治疗师告诉我，我有依恋障碍，我的精神疾病与童年有关。我离开了那些治疗师，不再理睬他们。
But it's not just those early years without my parents that branded me. It's the life I've lead in America as a migrant. As an undocumented person, I felt like a hologram. Nothing felt secure. I never felt safe. I didn't allow myself to feel joy because I was scared to attach myself to anything I'd have to let go of. Being deportable means you have to be ready to go at any moment. I've never loved a material object. When my parents took me home after my Harvard graduation, we took the Chinatown bus, and we each took one suitcase of my things. If it didn't fit, we threw it out. We threw out everything that wasn't clothes.
但品牌化我的不仅仅是那些没有父母的早年岁月。这是我作为一个移民在美国过的生活。作为一个无证的人，我感觉像个全息图。一切都感觉不到安全。我从没感到安全。我不允许自己感受到快乐，因为我害怕依恋任何我不得不放手的东西。随时会被驱逐意味着你必须随时准备离开。我从没爱过任何物质对象。我父母在我哈佛毕业后带我回家时，我们坐了唐人街巴士，我们每人带了一个装我东西的行李箱。如果装不下，我们就扔掉。我们扔掉了所有不是衣服的东西。
After I graduated from Harvard, I went to Yale to do a PhD. I never wanted to PhD. But DACA didn't exist then, and I couldn't legally get a job anywhere. And I had to buy time for something to happen-- for the DREAM Act to pass, which my dad had assured me would happened since I was in middle school. And I needed the health insurance.
从哈佛毕业后，我去了耶鲁读博士。我从来没想要读博。但那时还没有DACA，我在任何地方都不能合法地找到工作。我必须争取时间等待某件事发生——比如《梦想法案》（DREAM Act）通过，我父亲从我中学起就向我保证会发生。而且我需要健康保险。
It's allowed me to write, and my parents will be proud when I get that doctorate. I have fetched the American dream and laid it at my parents' feet. But the twisted inversion that many children of immigrants know is that, at some point, your parents become your children. And your own personal American dream becomes making sure they age and die with dignity in a country that has long wanted them dead.
它让我能够写作，当我拿到博士学位时，我父母会感到自豪。我 fetch（获取）了美国梦，并把它放在我父母脚下。但许多移民子女所知道的扭曲倒置是，在某个时刻，你的父母成了你的孩子。而你自己的个人美国梦变成了确保他们在长期想要他们死亡的国家里体面地老去并离世。
A few years ago, my father experienced heart failure. This was the moment I had been preparing for my entire life. Everything that had happened to me since I took that New York-bound flight 24 years ago had been preparing me for this moment. Learning English, getting bangs, gaining weight, losing weight, getting the sick puppy from the pet shop-- all of that happened to prepare me to this point. My parents were sick, undocumented, uninsured, and aging out of work in a fucking racist country.
几年前，我父亲经历了心力衰竭。这是我一生都在准备的时刻。自从24年前我坐上那架飞往纽约的飞机以来发生的一切，都在为这一刻做准备。学习英语、剪刘海、增重、减肥、从宠物店买那只生病的小狗——这一切都是为了准备好面对这一刻。我父母生病了，没有证件，没有保险，在这个该死的种族主义国家里老去，无法再工作。
Until the pandemic hit, my father was a salad maker, feeding Manhattan's executive class. He had worked for 14 years at the same restaurant, then left. He was invited to a promising new job, lured there by an acquaintance who assured him of better hours, better treatment, a better environment. My dad is very gullible.
直到疫情袭来，我父亲一直是个沙拉制作工，养活曼哈顿的高管阶层。他在同一家餐馆工作了14年，然后离开了。他受邀去了一份前途无量的这份新工作，被一个向他保证有更好的时间、更好的待遇、更好的环境的熟人诱惑了。我爸很容易轻信别人。
He spent a week at this new restaurant, where, for spare change, they had him work all day. And then at the end of the day, he was given just two and a half hours to clean an industrial kitchen-- an industrial fryer, a refrigerator, a stove, an oven, and a sink-- wash the dishes in the dishwasher, take out the trash, sweep and mop the floors, and clean the garbage chute. His body was wrecked at the end of each day. I'm too old to for this, he said. So he quit. His old job wouldn't take him back.
他在那家新餐馆待了一周，为了微薄的报酬，他们让他整天工作。然后在那天结束时，只给他两个半小时来清洁一个工业厨房——一个工业炸锅、一个冰箱、一个炉灶、一个烤箱和一个水槽——洗碗机里的餐具，倒垃圾，扫地拖地，清洁垃圾槽。他每天结束时身体都垮了。“我老得干不动这个了，”他说。所以他辞职了。他的老东家不肯录用他回去。
Desperate, he began each morning by showing up at a Latinx job agency, which would send him out to audition at a different restaurant day after day, week after week, to no avail. My dad started texting me blurry cell phone pictures from the job agency. He took the photos when he was sitting in the waiting room of the agency, waiting for his name to be called.
绝望中，他每天早上开始前往一个拉丁裔职业介绍所，那家介绍所会把他送出去，日复一日、周复一周地去不同的餐馆试工，却毫无收获。我爸开始给我发那些从职业介绍所拍的模糊手机照片。他是坐在介绍所等候室里等名字被叫到时拍的照片。
The first picture is of a man, maybe in his late 70s, wearing a green button down, khaki pants, and aviator sunglasses. His lips are downcast. My dad said he was applying to be a dishwasher. The second picture is of a man, maybe in his late 40s, who was wearing a black baseball cap, a gray sweater, and maroon pants. My dad said he'd had a stroke. His right arm was paralyzed, and he had a limp and his right leg. He was also applying to be a dishwasher.
第一张照片是一个大约70多岁的男人，穿着一件绿色扣领衬衫，卡其裤和飞行员太阳镜。他的嘴唇向下。我爸说他在申请做洗碗工。第二张照片是一个大约40多岁的男人，戴着黑色棒球帽，灰色毛衣，酒红色裤子。我爸说他中风了。他的右臂瘫痪，走路一瘸一拐，右腿不便。他也申请做洗碗工。
It's hard to see men like that not get jobs, my dad texted. I hope they have children who can take care of them, I respond. What I mean to say is, I hope they have a child like me. I hope everyone has a child like me. I tell god, this is going to kill me anyway, so just take me. Patent and mass produce and distribute me to undocumented immigrants at Walmarts. I am a professional undocumented immigrant's daughter.
“看到那样的人找不到工作很难受，”我爸发短信说。“我希望他们有能照顾他们的孩子，”我回复道。我的意思是，我希望他们能有个像我这样的孩子。我希望每个人都有个像我这样的孩子。我跟上帝说，反正这也会杀了我，所以直接带我走吧。给无证移民申请专利并批量生产和分发我。我是专业的无证移民女儿。
I saved the photos on my phone as a reminder to myself of why I need to be successful, so successful, statistical anomaly successful. Then I deleted them because they harmed my mental health. I wish I still had them.
我把照片保存在手机里，提醒自己为什么我需要成功，如此成功，统计学异常地成功。然后我删除了它们，因为它们损害了我的心理健康。我希望我还能有它们。
My parents live in New York City, and after the pandemic hit in March, they lost their jobs. They're both in Queens, the center of the center of the epidemic. I've prohibited my father from doing dangerous gig work, like deliveries. And I've begun to financially support them both. My mom is immunocompromised. She has an extremely low white blood cell count.
我父母住在纽约市，3月疫情爆发后，他们丢了工作。他们都住在皇后区，那是疫情中心的中心。我禁止我父亲做危险的零工，比如送餐。我已经开始在经济上支持他们俩人。我妈免疫功能低下。她的白细胞计数极低。
I have really lovely dreams, crazy fucking cotton candy fantasy dreams, dreams that make my whole body feel warm, where I cut up my chest, no anesthesia, take out my lungs, and implant them into her chest with the tree stitch. And if I'm lucky, in the seconds I have before I die, I would be able to see her heart. We wouldn't even need a ventilator.
我有非常可爱的梦想，疯狂的棉花糖幻想般的梦想，让我全身感到温暖的梦想，在梦里我切开自己的胸膛，没有任何麻醉，取出肺部，通过树状缝合植入她的胸腔。如果幸运的话，在我临死前的几秒钟里，我就能看到她的心脏。我们甚至都不需要呼吸机。
There is a Harvard scholar named Roberto Gonzalez who has conducted longitudinal studies on the effects of undocumented life on young people. He found his subjects suffered chronic headaches, toothaches, ulcers, sleep problems, and eating issues, which is funny to find in research because I get these migraines, an 8 or 9 on the 10 point scale. I have a CAT scan, an MRI. I go to the neurologist. The readings are all inconclusive. I'm told it's a migraine with an unknown cause. Have you tried yoga, they say.
有一位名叫罗伯托·冈萨雷斯（Roberto Gonzalez）的哈佛学者，他对无证生活对年轻人的影响进行了纵向研究。他发现他的受试者患有慢性头痛、牙痛、溃疡、睡眠问题和饮食问题，这在研究中发现很有趣，因为我也会有这种偏头痛，10分制里有8或9分那么严重。我做了CT扫描、核磁共振。我去看了神经科医生。读数都不确定。我被告知这是原因不明的偏头痛。他们说，你试过瑜伽吗？
The headaches get worse when I write about my parents. From migrants shot in the head by Border Patrol, to migrant children being forcibly injected with drugs in detention centers, US government's crimes against immigrants are beyond the pale. And the whole world knows. But when I was growing up and throughout the Obama administration, similar crimes were happening, if on a different scale, and I'm not sure the same people cared.
当我写到我父母时，头痛会加剧。从被边境巡逻队击中头部的移民，到被拘留中心强行注射药物的移民儿童，美国政府对移民的罪行令人发指。全世界都知道。但当我成长过程中，在奥巴马政府期间，类似的罪行也在发生，尽管规模不同，我不确定同样的人是否关心。
I felt crazy for thinking we were under attack, watching my neighbors disappear and then going to school, and watching the nightly news, and watching award shows and seeing no mention. I felt crazy watching the white supremacist state slowly kill my father. I would frantically tell everyone that there was no such thing as the American dream. But then some all-star immigrants around me, who had done things the right way, preached a different story, and Americans ate that up. It all made me feel crazy. I also am crazy. Pero why?
我因为认为我们受到攻击而感到疯狂，看着邻居们消失，然后去学校，看着晚间新闻，看着颁奖典礼，却没有看到任何提及。我看着白人至上主义国家慢慢杀死我的父亲，感到自己快疯了。我会疯狂地告诉每个人，根本没有所谓的美国梦。但随后我周围的一些全明星移民，那些“用正确方式”做事的人，宣扬了不同的故事，而美国人照单全收。这一切让我感到疯狂。我本身也很疯狂。但为什么？
Researchers have shown that the flooding of stress hormones resulting from a traumatic separation from your parents at a young age kills off so many dendrites and neurons in the brain that it results in permanent psychological and physical changes. One psychiatrist I went to told me that my brain looks like a tree without branches. So I just think about all the children who have been separated from their parents, and there's a lot of us, past and present, and some under more traumatic circumstances than others, like those who are in internment camps right now.
研究表明，年幼时因与父母创伤性分离而导致的压力荷尔蒙泛滥，会杀死大脑中太多的树突和神经元，从而导致永久性的心理和生理变化。我去过的一位精神科医生告诉我，我的大脑看起来像一棵没有树枝的树。所以我只是在想所有那些与父母分离的孩子，我们有很多，过去和现在，有些比其他人处于更具创伤性的环境中，比如那些现在就在拘留营里的人。
And I just imagine us as an army of mutants. What will happen to us? Who will we become? Who will take care of us? We've all been touched by this monster, and our brains are forever changed, all of us trees without branches.
我只是把我们想象成一支变种人军队。我们会发生什么？我们会变成谁？谁来照顾我们？我们都被这个怪物触碰过，我们的大脑被永远改变了，我们所有人都是没有树枝的树。
Karla Cornejo Villavicencio reading an essay adapted from her brand new memoir, The Undocumented Americans.
卡拉·科内霍·维拉维森西奥朗读了一篇改编自她全新回忆录《无证美国人》（The Undocumented Americans）的文章。
Coming up, a meaningless high school competition that, years later, becomes very, very meaningful. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一场毫无意义的高中比赛，多年后变得非常有意义。节目在芝加哥公共广播电台的片刻后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Embiggening, stories where new details arrive that embiggen in the picture-- and thank you The Simpsons, by the way, for that word-- and change everything. We have arrived at act two of our show. Act 2, Popular Vote.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“扩张”（Embiggening），故事里会有新的细节加入，从而扩展了画面——顺便感谢《辛普森一家》贡献了这个词——并改变了一切。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，普选。
So there are times when you discover an information gap in your own past, something you thought you knew everything about. After all, it happened to you. And then somebody comes along and says, no, it didn't happen like that at all. What do you do with that new information? Sean Cole has a story like that. It begins more than a decade ago at a high school. Here's Sean.
所以，有时你会发现自己过去的记忆中存在信息缺口，你以为你对自己过去的一切了如指掌。毕竟，那是发生在你身上的事。然后有人站出来说，不，根本不是那样发生的。你该怎么处理这些新信息？肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）有一个这样的故事。它开始于十多年前的一所高中。这是肖恩的故事。
The school was Granada Hills Charter High School, GHCHS. It's in the suburbs of LA. Huge, more than 4,500 kids enrolled right now. It's the largest charter school in the country. And in the spring of 2007, it engaged in one of the most hallowed of American high school traditions, senior superlatives. You might have had these at your school. Kids vote each other most likely to succeed, best smile, cutest couple. Marc Snetiker was one of those kids.
学校是格拉纳达山特许高中（GHCHS）。它位于洛杉矶郊区。规模巨大，目前有超过4500名学生在读。它是全国最大的特许学校。2007年春天，它参与了美国高中最神圣的传统之一——毕业班最高荣誉评选（senior superlatives）。你们学校可能也有过。孩子们投票评选“最可能成功”、“最佳笑容”、“最可爱的情侣”。马克·斯内蒂克（Marc Snetiker）就是其中之一。
I've been embarrassed about my superlatives for 10 years.
十年来，我一直对我的荣誉称号感到尴尬。
Have you been?
是吗？
I mean, I won most school spirited. Nobody wants to win most school spirited. I put all of my closeted gay energy into school spirit. You know what I mean? I did the morning announcements. I was on student council. I did theater. I loved high school.
我的意思是，我赢得了“最有校精神奖”。没人想赢这个。我把所有隐晦的同性恋能量都投入到了校精神中。你懂我的意思吗？我负责早间广播。我在学生会。我参加戏剧社。我爱死高中了。
He also won a category called all around senior. You were allowed to compete in two categories but no more than that. And GHCHS really put a lot into these superlatives. There was an election, like usual, with paper ballots. But instead of announcing the winners over the intercom or posting them on a hallway bulletin board, there was this event run by the Senior Leadership Council, which Marc was on-- a big ceremony and trophies. All of the winners received a little replica of the Oscar statuette.
他还赢得了“全能毕业生”奖。每个人最多允许参加两个类别的比赛，不能更多。GHCHS确实在这些荣誉上下了不少功夫。像往常一样有选举，使用纸质选票。但不是通过对讲机公布获胜者或把它们贴在走廊的公告栏上，而是由毕业班领导委员会举办的活动——马克也在其中——有盛大的仪式和奖杯。所有获奖者都收到了一座小小的奥斯卡奖杯复制品。
It wasn't unlike a roast. All the seniors were in our auditorium. And I think I actually-- now that I'm realizing it, I think I helped give them out.
这和吐槽大会差不多。所有毕业生都在礼堂里。我想我实际上——现在我意识到了，我想我曾帮忙分发它们。
I see.
我明白了。
But I do remember reading names of some of my friends and cheering them on. And all of my best friends all won things.
但我确实记得念出一些朋友的名字并为他们欢呼。我所有的好朋友都赢得了什么。
Which make sense. Marc was popular. His friends were popular. But that was 13 years ago, and he hadn't been thinking too much about the superlatives until recently.
这说得通。马克很受欢迎。他的朋友们也很受欢迎。但那是13年前的事了，直到最近他才想起这些荣誉称号。
I was at home, cooking dinner. And I got a text from my friend.
我当时在家做晚饭。我收到朋友发来的短信。
A friend from high school.
高中朋友。
And all it said was, please stop what you're doing and read this.
短信只写着：“请停下你手头的事读这个。”
It was a Facebook post, posted to a private Facebook group for Marc's high school class, the class of 2007. Marc's not on Facebook, so it was the first he was seeing it. And the text wasn't just to Marc. Four other buddies from high school were on it as well.
那是一个Facebook帖子，发布在马克高中班级（2007届）的一个私密小组里。马克不用Facebook，所以这是他第一次看到。这条短信不仅发给了马克。还有其他四个高中好友也收到了。
We all read it. And immediately, we were all freaking out. I can't believe this. Oh my god, this makes so much sense.
我们都读了。然后立刻，我们都惊呆了。“不敢相信。天哪，这太合理了。”
I wonder if you could just read the post. Do you have it there?
我好奇你能不能读一下那个帖子。你有它吗？
Totally. So he said, "Hey, guys, one more thing before I forget. In the spirit of the new year, I'd like to take this opportunity to confess to all of you that I and one or two other members of Senior Leadership Council '07, who will remain unnamed, interfered with the class of 2007 senior superlatives. This is not a joke. We went to great lengths to forge no less than 30 filled out ballots, with all of our friends and acquaintances winning their respective categories. We attempted to rig literally every category."
当然。所以他说：“嘿伙计们，还有一件事在我忘记之前说。本着新年的精神，我想借此机会向你们所有人坦白，我和另外一两个毕业班领导委员会的成员（名字将保密）干涉了2007届的毕业班最高荣誉评选。这不是玩笑。我们费了很大功夫伪造了至少30张填好的选票，让我们的所有朋友和熟人赢得了各自的类别。我们试图操纵字面上的每一个类别。”
So classic ballot stuffing, with 30 forged ballots, at least. The perpetrator goes on to say that not everyone he tried to fix the election for actually won. And the nominees for each category, the choices on the ballot, those were all legit. It's just the outcome that was now in question. Again, this confession was coming 13 years after the fact.
非常经典的塞票箱操作，至少塞了30张伪造选票。肇事者继续说，并不是他试图操纵选举的每一个人都真的赢了。每个类别的提名者，选票上的选择，那些都是合法的。只是现在结果成了疑问。再次强调，这个坦白是在13年后才做出的。
"Wow, I feel such a weight lifted off my shoulders having finally confessed this. Thank you for reading." Oh my god.
“哇，终于坦白了，我感觉如释重负。谢谢你们阅读。”天哪。
Now, it's not like Marc has been sitting around for the last 13 years clinging to as mini Oscar trophy, defining himself by his superlatives. Since high school, he's poured is no longer closeted energy into entertainment-- worked for Entertainment Weekly for a long time, just moved over to Netflix. But it's not like he thinks he didn't deserve his awards.
现在，马克并不是过去13年一直抱着奥斯卡奖杯不放，以自己的这些荣誉称号定义自己。高中毕业后，他把他那些不再隐晦的能量投入到了娱乐业——在《娱乐周刊》工作了很久，刚转到Netflix。但他并不觉得自己的奖项名不虚传。
Whether or not he rigged-- it's interesting to think about who really was rigged. Because me, I really, objectively was very school spirited.
无论他是否操纵了选举——思考究竟是谁被操纵了，这很有趣。因为就我而言，我客观上确实非常有集体荣誉感。
And very all-around seniory. And a couple of friends on the text thread felt the same way. One of them said, "Do you think people don't believe I had best eyes?"
而且是非常全面的资深人士。群聊里的几个朋友也感同身受。其中一个人说：“你觉得大家不相信我有最好的视力吗？”
We particularly were interested because the five of us all won. We all won some different superlative, and we all thought that was pretty cool. Because I think, ultimately, high school senior superlatives are-- I mean, it's complicated. Right? They are absolutely meaningless. And yet, at the time, they are such a huge deal because they are peer-voted. And nobody wants their memories tampered with or invalidated. Right? Subconsciously, we're all thinking to ourselves, oh my god, what would 18-year-old me have thought about this?
我们特别感兴趣，因为我们五个都获奖了。我们每个人都获得了不同的奖项，我们都觉得这很酷。因为我认为，归根结底，高中毕业生的奖项是——我的意思是，这很复杂，对吧？它们完全毫无意义。然而在当时，它们却又是如此重要，因为这是由同龄人投票选出的。没有人希望自己的记忆被篡改或否定，对吧？潜意识里，我们都在想，天哪，18岁的我会怎么看这件事？
Yeah.
是啊。
That's really at the core of all this. We're all having imaginary conversations with our 18-year-old selves, thinking, oh my god, he can never know. This will uproot him. This will unravel him to find out.
这确实是这一切的核心。我们都在和18岁的自己进行着想象中的对话，心想，天哪，他永远不能知道。这会让他彻底崩溃，这会让他发现真相后心神不宁。
Which probably explains what happened next. In short, Marc posted a screenshot of the confession to Twitter, not thinking much about it, went off to the gym. And when he came back, it had exploded-- more than 150,000 likes and retweets and comments at this point, most of them not GHCHS alums.
这可能解释了接下来发生的事情。简而言之，马克把那份坦白的截图发到了推特上，当时没多想，就去健身房了。等他回来时，事情已经彻底发酵了——到目前为止，已经有超过15万的点赞、转发和评论，其中大多数人都不是查茨沃斯高中（GHCHS）的校友。
Weirdly, a lot of people wrote that the same thing had happened at their high school, or that they themselves had rigged the superlatives election, or had always suspected superlatives were rigged, and now here was proof. And a couple of people pointed out something that I noticed too, that the perpetrator never actually apologizes in his message.
奇怪的是，很多人写道，在他们的高中也发生过同样的事情，或者他们自己曾经操纵过毕业纪念册的评选，又或者一直怀疑评选是被操纵的，而现在这就是证据。还有几个人指出了我也注意到的一个细节：肇事者在信息中从未真正道歉。
I didn't know this was going to go viral. I thought this was going to be shared with 400 people in my high school senior class Facebook page, and that was it.
我没想到这会火。我本来以为这只会在我高中毕业班的 Facebook 页面上分享给 400 个人，仅此而已。
This is Michael Barlevav, rigger of high school elections, confessor of high school transgressions, 30 years old now, still living in LA. And I had about 100 questions for him, chief among them why it took him so long to come clean and what it had been like sitting with the weight of that guilt for so many years.
这位是迈克尔·巴列夫，高中选举的操盘手，高中罪行的忏悔者，如今已30岁，仍住在洛杉矶。我有一百个问题想问他，其中最主要的是，为什么他过了这么久才坦白，以及背负着那份愧疚感度过多年是种什么样的体验。
You say at the end of the confession-- hang on.
你在自白书的最后说——等等。
Wow, I feel such a weight lifted off my shoulders.
哇，我感觉如释重负。
Weight lifted off my shoulders. Yeah. Did you?
如释重负。是啊，你也是吗？
No, that was just me being-- that was just me being cynical.
不，那只是我在……那只是我在愤世嫉俗。
In truth, there was no weight, no guilt. In fact, Michael had wanted to come clean right away, but a bunch of more pressing things took his attention. He was diagnosed with cancer, actually. Went through treatment, got better, moved on. It was only when he saw his former classmates talking about a potential reunion on the Facebook page that he thought of all this again.
事实上，并没有所谓的沉重感或负罪感。其实，迈克尔本想立刻坦白一切，但一堆更紧迫的事情吸引了他的注意力。他当时被确诊患有癌症。他接受了治疗，病情好转，随后继续过自己的生活。直到他在Facebook页面上看到以前的同学讨论可能举行的聚会时，他才再次想起了这一切。
And the thing you need to know about Michael, unlike Marc, he was a slacker senior year, checked out, only interested in, his words, smoking weed and getting laid. And then he found out there's a superlative for that-- biggest case of senioritis.
你需要了解迈克尔的一点是，他和马克不同，他大四那年很懒散，心不在焉，用他自己的话来说，只对抽大麻和约炮感兴趣。后来他发现还有个专门形容这种状态的词——“大四综合症”最严重病例。
And I remember begging everybody in my homeroom to nominate me. And I asked all my friends. I was like, I really want to get senioritis. I want this.
我还记得我恳求班里的每个人提名我。我问遍了所有的朋友。我说，我真的想获得“毕业即懈怠症”这个奖。我想要这个。
Because he was competitive about being a slacker. And organized about it-- he only picked four super easy classes senior year, including, he says, Senior Leadership Council, which ran the election. So he knew that no one would notice if, during class, he and an accomplice hung out for a while near the ballot box, where there also happened to be a stack of blank ballots handy. And one thing Michael learned right away, rigging an election can be complicated.
因为他在“做个懒人”这件事上都充满了胜负欲。而且他非常有条理——高三那年，他只选了四门超级简单的课，其中还包括他所说的“学生会领导力课程”，该课程负责选举事宜。所以他知道，如果他和同伙在课间去投票箱附近晃悠，没人会注意到，而那里恰好就有一叠现成的空白选票。迈克尔立刻学到的一点是，操纵选举可能会很复杂。
There was actually one category, I remember, where two girls were both nominated.
我记得确实有一个奖项，两名女孩同时获得了提名。
Nominated for the same category.
获得同一类别的提名。
And we were friends with both of them. And so we just filled out an equal number of ballots for each of them, because I didn't want a favor-- I didn't want to favor either one because I liked them both.
我们和他们俩都是朋友。所以我们给他们每个人都填了相同数量的选票，因为我不想偏袒任何一方，因为我都很喜欢他们。
Was it a kind of thing we're other people really wanted a certain superlative? Or were-- I mean, you really wanted biggest case of senioritis, and you were begging people in your homeroom to nominate you for that.
那是那种大家都很想要某个最高级奖项的情况吗？还是说——我的意思是，你真的很想要“最严重高三综合症”这个头衔，所以才求着你班上的同学提名你吗？
Well, let's not-- let's not go crazy. I wasn't begging anybody. OK?
好吧，别——别太夸张了。我没有求任何人，好吗？
I'm sorry, folks. Just pausing here. Can we go back to that tape we played 60 seconds ago?
抱歉，各位。暂停一下。我们能回到60秒前播放的那段录音吗？
And I remember begging everybody in my homeroom to nominate me.
我记得我当时求遍了班里所有人提名我。
Thank you. Anyway, votes were in, ballot box was stuffed. And it came time for that big event where they announced all the winners.
谢谢。总之，投票结束了，票箱也被塞满了。随后就到了宣布所有获奖者的盛大时刻。
The whole time I was super nervous. Every time a new category was being announced-- the winners were being announced, I was like, oh man, are we going to win this one? Are we going to win this one? Are we going to win this one?
整个过程中我一直非常紧张。每次宣布新的类别，当获奖者名单即将公布时，我都在想，天哪，我们会赢这一项吗？我们会赢吗？我们会赢吗？
And every time somebody was announced as the winner, I was like, ooh, that guy won because of me. Or it was like, oh shit, the girl that I wanted to win didn't win. Because like I said, not everybody that we tried to fix it for won. And then when my friend who helped me rig it won his category and then when I won my category, it was just-- it was just so sweet. I'll never forget it.
每当有人宣布获奖时，我就心想，哦，那家伙是因为我才赢的。或者心想，该死，我希望赢的那个女孩没赢。因为就像我说的，并不是每个我们试图操纵的人都能赢。然后，当那个帮我作弊的朋友赢了他的奖项，而我也赢了自己的奖项时，那种感觉真是太棒了。我永远都不会忘记。
They announced the winners, and the winners would go up on stage. We got our trophies.
他们宣布了获胜者，获胜者会走上舞台。我们拿到了奖杯。
And then he went backstage for a picture that would go into the yearbook, which was important to him, proof of his victory.
然后他去后台拍了一张照片，这张照片将会被收入年鉴，这对通过他来说很重要，是他获胜的证明。
It was something that I would never forget. There would be a page in the yearbook reminding me and my friend that we interfered with this shit and that all of our friends, or most of our friends, won their category, whether or not they would have otherwise. I wanted to make it absurd, like ridiculous, preposterous. Some of the people who won their categories absolutely should not have won their categories.
那是我永远不会忘记的事情。毕业纪念册上会有那么一页，提醒我和我的朋友，我们曾干涉过这件烂事，而且我们所有的朋友，或者说大多数朋友，都赢得了他们各自的奖项，无论他们本该是否能赢。我想让这一切变得荒唐，变得可笑、离谱。有些赢得奖项的人根本就不应该获胜。
And that delighted him in a diabolical way. It did then, and it does now. The lack of apology in his confession wasn't just an oversight.
这让他感到一种恶魔般的快意。当时如此，现在亦然。他供述中缺乏歉意，这并非仅仅是疏忽。
What is there to apologize for? What is there to apologize for, honestly? Yeah, I was an asshole. Yeah, what I did was dishonest. Yeah, it was shady. Yeah, it was insensitive. But I would definitely do it again the exact same way--
有什么好道歉的？说真的，有什么好道歉的？没错，我是个混蛋。没错，我的所作所为确实不诚实。没错，那是不光彩的。没错，那是冷酷无情的。但我绝对会用同样的方式再做一次——
Really?
是真的吗？
--if I had-- absolutely. I wouldn't do anything differently. I think it's going to be a net positive impact. At least I hope so, man. I hope that what people take away from this is that you should not put value into things that are so arbitrary and silly, like popularity and who has the best hair, or the best smile, or who's the biggest flirt, or who's the most likely to become president, or who is most likely to whatever. It's just opinion, man. It's completely subjective. There's no meaning behind it.
——如果我有机会，绝对会。我什么都不会做得不同。我认为这会产生净积极影响。至少我希望如此，伙计。我希望人们从中学到的是，你不应该把价值寄托在那些如此随意和愚蠢的事情上，比如人气，谁有最好的头发，谁有最好的笑容，谁是最调情的人，谁最可能成为总统，或者谁最可能做任何事。这只是观点，伙计。这完全是主观的。背后没有任何意义。
Then Michael's heart's in the right place. But as far as I can tell, the person from Michael's high school class who's most concerned about these senior superlatives is Michael. If you squint at it for a second, he cared so much about getting an award for caring the least, the senioritis award, that he went to, quote, "great lengths to commit electoral fraud."
迈克尔的心是好的。但据我所知，迈克尔高中班级里最关心这些毕业班荣誉的人正是迈克尔本人。如果你稍微眯着眼看，他为了获得一个“关心最少”的奖项——那个毕业倦怠奖，竟然关心到了去“费尽心机搞选举欺诈”的地步。
Also, in the comments below his Facebook confession and my conversations with some of his classmates, no one else seems at all invested at this point in who won or lost.
此外，在他Facebook坦白帖子下的评论区以及我与他的一些同学的谈话中，似乎没有任何人目前对谁输谁赢感兴趣。
We all were just dying of laughter.
我们都笑得快死过去了。
Elush Shirazpour was awarded class clown in 2007. He says he and his friends were not the least upset reading Michael's Facebook post.
埃卢什·希拉兹普尔（Elush Shirazpour）在2007年被评为“班级小丑”。他说他和朋友们读到迈克尔的Facebook帖子时一点也不生气。
We just laughed and joked about this. And I have some friend that lost. And we said, oh, it was you! They rigged it against you!
我们只是笑着开玩笑。我有一些输掉的朋友。我们说：“噢，原来是你！他们为了你操纵选举！”
Like you were the one who should have gotten it?
就像你是那个本该获奖的人？
Yeah, exactly. But yeah, apparently the deep state senior superlative council got to them.
嗯，确实。但显然，那个“深层政府毕业班最高荣誉委员会”盯上他们了。
Did it make you question whether or not you were actually the class clown?
这有没有让你质疑自己是否真的是班级小丑？
I think, for sure, I won--
我认为，我绝对赢了——
Fair and square?
名副其实？
I think so. I like to think I was funny. Back in high school, I was 5'2", very short and looked very young for my age.
我想是吧。我喜欢认为自己很幽默。高中时，我身高只有5尺2，非常矮，看起来比实际年龄年轻得多。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
So all I had was a personality. So that's all I could do.
所以我拥有的只有性格。所以这是我唯一能做的。
Pretty much everyone I talked to felt this way. Since there's no way of really knowing, they were like, sure, maybe somebody else got a superlative they shouldn't have gotten, but mine was totally deserved.
我交谈过的几乎每个人都有这种感觉。既然没有办法真正知道，他们的心态是：好吧，也许有人赢得了他们本不该获得的荣誉，但我的是完全名副其实的。
My girlfriend, Eva, and I won cutest couple.
我女朋友伊娃（Eva）和我在2007年赢得了“最可爱情侣”。
This is David Vigodnier. He's a nursing student in Colorado now.
这是大卫·维戈德尼尔（David Vigodnier）。他现在是科罗拉多州的护理系学生。
And that, for sure, wasn't rigged.
那个奖项肯定不是操纵的。
Because you are the cutest couple?
因为你们确实是最可爱的情侣？
I mean, we're still together.
我的意思是，我们现在还在一起。
He was at home studying when I called him.
我给他打电话时，他正在家里学习。
Eva--
伊娃——
His girlfriend, Eva, was there too. She's pursuing a doctorate in psychology.
他的女朋友伊娃也在那里。她正在攻读心理学博士。
Did you know the other couples that were up for cutest couple?
你知道当时还有哪些情侣竞选最可爱情侣吗？
I honestly don't remember.
老实说我不记得了。
Insert a joke about it didn't really matter, because we weren't going to lose.
插一句玩笑话，那根本不重要，因为我们不会输。
Stop! Oh my god.
停！我的天。
Aww.
噢。
Oh my god.
我的天。
If I only knew which names Michael checked off on those fake ballots, I could ask those people what they thought now, if all of this changed anything for them. But Michael refused to give me those names. It was one thing confessing to what he did in a general way. But pointing to individual people and saying, they wouldn't have won if not for me, that just seemed mean and unnecessary.
如果我能知道迈克尔在那些假选票上勾选了哪些名字，我就能问问那些人现在的想法，看看这一切是否对他们有什么改变。但迈克尔拒绝提供这些名字。以笼统的方式坦白他所做的事是一回事。但指着个人说“如果不是我，他们根本赢不了”，那看起来就太刻薄且没必要了。
I did end up asking him about one person in particular-- Marc Snetiker, who posted Michael's confession on Twitter. They were in Senior Leadership Council together.
我最终问了他关于一个人的情况——在Twitter上发布迈克尔坦白帖子的马克·斯内蒂克。他们曾在毕业班领导委员会共事。
Yeah! I knew Marc very well. He was really popular. Yeah.
对！我很了解马克。他很受欢迎。对。
At this point, Michael took a peak in the old yearbook he'd brought along with him for the interview.
此时，迈克尔看了一眼他带去采访的旧毕业纪念册。
Yeah. So he won most cool spirited, and he won all around senior.
对。所以他赢得了最有校精神奖，还赢得了全能毕业生奖。
Did he win those fair and square, or did he win those because you stuffed the ballot box?
他是名副其实地赢得了这些，还是因为你塞了选票才赢的？
You can't-- how the fuck am I supposed to know? That's the point, man. There's no way to know.
你不能——我他妈怎么知道？这就是重点，伙计。根本没法知道。
Did you vote for him on those ballots that you stuffed?
你在那些被你塞满的选票上投他了吗？
Before I answer that--
在我回答之前——
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
--let's acknowledge that it doesn't matter.
——让我们承认这不重要。
OK. We'll acknowledge that it doesn't matter.
好的。我们承认这不重要。
OK. So you acknowledge that this answer I'm about to give you is arbitrary. But I'm going to give it to you anyway.
好的。所以你承认我接下来要给你的这个回答是任意的。但我还是要给你。
OK, good.
好的，很好。
Yeah. Yeah, I voted for-- I wanted him to win because he was a good guy.
对。对，我投票给了——我希望他赢，因为他是个好人。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Yeah. So he was definitely one of the guys I fixed it for, for sure.
对。所以他绝对是我搞定的人之一，毫无疑问。
I told Marc what Michael said.
我把迈克尔说的话告诉了马克。
Oh, my god! But at the same time, girl, who is to say that everybody else didn't think I was a good guy too, honey? You know? Come on. I mean, look, if he deemed as good friends enough to have rigged it for me, cool. Thanks a lot, dude. You have labeled me as most cool spirited for 10 years, and I would happily disavow myself of that. Yeah.
我的天！但与此同时，女孩，谁能说其他人不觉得我也是个好人呢，亲爱的？你知道吗？拜托。我的意思是，听着，如果他认为我作为好朋友值得他为我操纵选票，酷。非常感谢，伙计。你给我贴了十年的“最有校精神”标签，我很乐意撕掉它。对。
Oh, you know, I-- this makes me smile, because Michael was fun. We had a good time in high school together. So it's nice to hear that he believed in me enough to rig votes in my favor.
噢，你知道，我——这让我微笑，因为迈克尔很有趣。我们高中时一起度过了美好的时光。所以听到他足够信任我，愿意为了让我赢而操纵选票，感觉很好。
In other words, while Michael worried that learning the news might make Marc feel bad, it didn't come close. In fact, the opposite.
换句话说，虽然迈克尔担心听到这个消息会让马克感到难过，但根本没那回事。事实上，恰恰相反。
But here's the real effect that Michael's rigging the election had, in the way that he did it. Because it was just 30 fake ballots, in effect, what he's done is create a superlative sized black hole of information for everyone involved. Like he says, a lot of the winners might have won anyway, but they might not have. A lot of the losers might have lost anyway, but maybe they would have won.
但迈克尔操纵选举的做法真正造成的影响是这样的。因为只有30张假选票，他实际上为所有参与者制造了一个毕业班荣誉称号大小的“信息黑洞”。就像他说的，很多获胜者可能本来就会赢，但也可能不会。很多失败者可能本来就会输，但也可能本来会赢。
So what we're left with is an extremely rare occurrence-- I can't think of another one-- in which a brand new piece of definitive, clear information that the election was rigged actually makes it so that everyone knows less than they did before.
所以我们剩下的是一个极其罕见的事件——我想不出另一个——即关于选举被操纵的全新、清晰的决定性信息，实际上让大家知道的反而比以前更少了。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our program.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act 3, Tunnel Vision.
第三幕，隧道视野。
So this story was first on our show back in 2015. That was the year Canada hosted the Pan American Games. But a few months before the games began, somebody made a mysterious discovery close to the Toronto venue for the games. It was a secret tunnel.
所以这个故事最早是在2015年的节目中播出的。那是加拿大举办泛美运动会的一年。但在运动会开始前几个月，有人在多伦多比赛场馆附近发现了一个神秘发现。那是一条秘密隧道。
And it wasn't just some shabby, half-baked construction. This is tall enough to stand in, 33 feet long, with support beams, a plywood ceiling, walls. It had water-resistant lighting, a generator, a sump pump to pump out groundwater. And at the end of the tunnel, two little rooms were still under construction. Even more intriguing, the decor-- a rosary and a plastic red poppy nailed to the wall. Canadians use the poppy to commemorate fallen soldiers on Remembrance Day.
这可不是什么破烂、草率的建筑。它有33英尺长，足够站立，带有支撑梁、胶合板天花板、墙壁。它有防水照明、发电机、用于抽出地下水的污水泵。在隧道尽头，两个小房间还在建设中。更令人好奇的是装饰——一个钉在墙上的念珠和一个塑料红罂粟。加拿大人用罂粟纪念在阵亡将士纪念日牺牲的士兵。
In the United States, all this got a little bit of coverage. But in Canada, in 2015, it was big news.
在美国，这一切得到了一些报道。但在加拿大，2015年，这是大新闻。
No one knows who dug the 30-foot-long tunnel near the site of this year's Pan American Games in Toronto.
没有人知道是谁在多伦多今年的泛美运动会场馆附近挖掘了这条30英尺长的隧道。
A bizarre tunnel found near one of the venues for the upcoming Pan Am Games has sparked fears of an imminent terror attack.
在即将到来的泛美运动会场馆附近发现的怪异隧道引发了对迫在眉睫的恐怖袭击的担忧。
Rarely has a dirt tunnel received so much attention.
泥土隧道很少受到如此多的关注。
No one knows why it was created. Do you think someone told their kid to dig to China and the kid actually tried?
没人知道它是为了什么建造的。你认为有人告诉孩子挖到中国，而那孩子真的试了吗？
It's not just the sophistication that police say is troubling, but the lack of suspects or a motive.
警方表示，令人不安的不仅是其复杂性，还有嫌疑人和动机的缺失。
When something unexplained like this happens, of course people go nuts, speculating about what it could be. In this case, the media pondered whether the tunnel would be used to plant a bomb at the upcoming Pan Am games nearby. The Pan Am Games are like an Olympics for North and South and Central America.
当这种无法解释的事情发生时，人们当然会疯狂地猜测它可能是为了什么。在这个案例中，媒体思考这条隧道是否会用于在附近的泛美运动会上安放炸弹。泛美运动会就像是南北美洲的奥运会。
Or maybe somebody was going to build a meth lab in the tunnel, or an operation grow marijuana. Or they would use the tunnel to hide foreign athletes from the Pan Am Games who might want to stay in Canada illegally. On Twitter, it was hashtag #TerrorTunnel.
或者有人可能要在隧道里建一个冰毒实验室，或者一个大麻种植作业点。或者他们会用隧道隐藏想要非法留在加拿大的泛美运动会外籍运动员。在Twitter上，标签是#恐怖隧道（#TerrorTunnel）。
But the truth of what was going on in that tunnel, and what its purpose was, was nothing like any of that. And the way the Canadian police figured it out--
但隧道里究竟在发生什么，它的目的又是什么，与上述任何一种猜想都毫无关系。而加拿大警方查明真相的方式——
OK. First of all, can I say sometimes one is reminded of what a very different country Canada is from the United States. As part of the manhunt for whoever built the tunnel, a policeman tweeted, "If you built a tunnel near the Rexall Center in Toronto, give us a call, OK?" The Toronto Police pointed out that it is not illegal to dig a hole. Apparently, no law was broken. From the start, they said they saw no evidence of terrorism, and they did not want to jump to conclusions.
好的。首先，我能说有时人们会想起加拿大是一个与美国多么不同的国家吗？作为寻找隧道建造者搜捕行动的一部分，一名警察发推文说：“如果你在多伦多Rexall中心附近修了一条隧道，给我们打个电话，好吗？”多伦多警方指出，挖洞并不违法。显然，没有法律被破坏。从一开始，他们就说没有看到恐怖主义的证据，也不想妄下结论。
For instance, here's a exchange between then-Toronto Deputy Chief Mark Saunders and reporters after he showed them a photo of that rosary and plastic poppy.
例如，以下是当时的副局长马克·桑德斯（Mark Saunders）在向记者展示念珠和塑料罂粟照片后的对话。
This was found inside the actual tunnel itself, and it was nailed on the wall.
这确实是在隧道内部发现的，钉在墙上。
What does that tell you?
这告诉你什么？
That tells me that this was nailed inside the tunnel on a wall.
这告诉我它是钉在隧道墙上的。
The police basically went on TV and showed pictures of the stuff that they found in the tunnel-- a ladder and the generator and the sump pump. And they asked public, this jog anybody's memory? Anybody know anything about this stuff? And that turned out to be exactly the right move, because watching that coverage was a guy named Boko Marich. He sees that ladder--
警方基本上上了电视，展示了他们在隧道里发现的东西的照片——梯子、发电机和污水泵。他们问公众：“这让谁想起什么了吗？谁知道这些东西吗？”这被证明是完全正确的做法，因为看着报道的一个人叫博科·马里奇（Boko Marich）。他看到了那把梯子——
And I said to myself, they look exactly like my stepladder, and I bet you any money this is mine.
我对自己说：“它们看起来和我的梯子一模一样，我敢打赌这肯定是我的。”
I bet you any money this is mine.
我敢打赌这肯定是我的。
And then, when I saw sump pump, I said, oh, ho, ho, my stepladder and sump pump. But I couldn't believe-- I couldn't believe-- I couldn't believe myself. I couldn't sleep. I was thinking about that.
然后，当我看到污水泵时，我说：“噢，天啊，我的梯子和污水泵。”但我简直不敢相信——不敢相信——我自己。我彻夜难眠。我一直想着那件事。
He couldn't sleep because he knew who'd he given the stuff to. Bob is a contractor. And he lent that stuff to one of his favorite employees, this young guy, just 22, Elton. What was Elton doing? And come to think of it, Elton had been asking to borrow a lot of tools lately.
他睡不着是因为他知道他把东西给了谁。博科是一名承包商。他把那些东西借给了他最喜欢的员工之一，一个才22岁的年轻人，埃尔顿（Elton）。埃尔顿在做什么？回想起来，埃尔顿最近一直在借很多工具。
He was asking me or shovel, for pick, for another shovel, and other tools, so many tools. I just would say, OK, if you need, take.
他问我借铲子、十字镐，借另一把铲子，还有其他工具，好多工具。我只是说：“没问题，如果需要，拿去。”
Boko loves Elton. He loves that Elton's a great worker. He loves that, unlike other young people Bob's worked with in the past, apparently, Elton always wants to learn, asks lots of questions.
博科喜欢埃尔顿。他喜欢埃尔顿是个出色的工人。他喜欢埃尔顿不像他过去共事过的其他年轻人，总是想学习，问很多问题。
What do you do when you do the roof? How you connect this? How you put joist hangers? What is distance between in that? Can I do this instead of that? Is this going to carry this support? Unbelievable. You know? And I joked with everybody-- if everybody asks me, who's that guy? This is my adopted son, Elton. Always, I used to tell, this is my adopted son. OK.
“你做屋顶的时候怎么做？怎么连接这个？怎么放托梁吊架？那个之间的距离是多少？我能用这个代替那个吗？这能支撑那个吗？”简直不可思议。你知道吗？我跟每个人开玩笑——如果有人问我，那个人是谁？这是我的养子，埃尔顿。我总是说，这是我的养子。好的。
So I would lend him any tools he wanted.
所以我愿意借给他任何他想要的工具。
So the morning after he sees the police pointing to a photo of his ladder and sump pump on television, he goes to pick up Elton to bring it to work, like always. Elton gets in the truck.
所以在他看到警方在电视上指着他梯子和污水泵的照片的第二天早上，他像往常一样去接埃尔顿去上班。埃尔顿上了车。
He brought two coffees, for me and him. And I said, Elton, tell me one thing. That sump pump-- I didn't even ask full question. He said, Boko, yes, I did. Oh my god.
他带来了两杯咖啡，给我和他。我说：“埃尔顿，告诉我一件事。那个污水泵——”我甚至没问完整句话。他说：“博科，是的，是我做的。”天哪。
Boko went to the authorities and made sure that Elton would not get arrested or go to prison for this. And then he turned him in. The police talked to Elton, satisfied themselves that Elton was not a terrorist or an evil criminal mastermind, but just some guy. And they let him go. They didn't even give him a fine. Though they did suggest that he not dig more tunnels. Canada.
博科去当局说明情况，确保埃尔顿不会因此被逮捕或入狱。然后他把他交了出去。警方和埃尔顿谈了话，确认埃尔顿不是恐怖分子或邪恶的犯罪主谋，只是个普通人。他们放了他。甚至没开罚单。尽管他们建议他不要再挖隧道了。加拿大。
So who is Elton? Why did he do it? Why go to the trouble? Well, Elton has not given many interviews. Though he did allow one reporter named Nick Kohler to spend a couple days with him and his family to write this long story about them in MacLean's Magazine. And Nick was able to tell us a lot about Elton. Elton turned down our request for an interview.
那么埃尔顿是谁？他为什么要这么做？为什么要费这么大劲？好吧，埃尔顿没接受过多少采访。尽管他确实允许一位名叫尼克·科勒（Nick Kohler）的记者和他及家人待了几天，在《麦克林杂志》（Maclean's Magazine）上写了一篇关于他们的长文。尼克能够告诉我们很多关于埃尔顿的事。埃尔顿拒绝了我们的采访请求。
Elton lives maybe two minutes from the ravine and woods where the tunnel was found, in a kind of rough neighborhood in public housing. Nick says both of his parents are from Jamaica.
埃尔顿住在离发现隧道的沟壑和树林大约两分钟路程的地方，那是一个类似公共住房的粗糙社区。尼克说他的父母都来自牙买加。
He lives with two sisters, an older sister and a younger sister. And they all live with their mother.
他和两个姐妹住在一起，一个大姐和一个妹妹。他们都和母亲住在一起。
Elton's the quiet kid in the family. Nick says everybody else is a big talker.
埃尔顿是家里安静的那个孩子。尼克说其他人都是话痨。
And I think in particular, his older sister, Anora, she has a lot of ideas about how Elton should be living his life. And she's not shy about sharing that with him. She's a big fan of self-help books. And so I think Elton is often in the position of listening to life talks, as they put it.
尤其是他的大姐阿诺拉（Anora），她对埃尔顿应该过什么样的生活有很多想法。她不介意与他分享。她是个励志书籍迷。所以我认为埃尔顿经常处于听“人生讲座”的位置，用他们的话说。
Advice.
建议。
Advice. And Elton found refuge ever since he was a kid in the ravine.
建议。埃尔顿从小就把那个沟壑当作避难所。
In the ravine, there were no life talks. And from the time he was little, Elton was this introspective kid who loved to build, to take machines apart and put them back together. He fixed up old lawn mowers. He built clubhouses. And like he said in a short interview the Nick recorded for a video that MacLean's Magazine made, he'd go to the ravine.
在沟壑里，没有“人生讲座”。从很小的时候起，埃尔顿就是一个喜欢建造、拆解机器并重新组装的内向孩子。他修理旧割草机。他建造会所。正如他在尼克为《麦克林杂志》制作的视频中录下的简短采访中所说的那样，他会去沟壑。
OK. What I used to do in the ravine when I was a kid is run around, play hide and go seek. We'd play apple war. We would go fishing. But I started my first tunnel probably when I was in elementary school. I would just go in the creek, walk around. And this was something on my mind. I wanted to build a clubhouse. I had five or six attempts. And I think the sixth one was the huge tunnel that you guys found.
好的。我小时候在沟壑里做的事是到处跑，玩捉迷藏。我们玩“苹果战争”。我们会去钓鱼。但我大概小学时就开始建我的第一个隧道了。我会走进小溪，四处走走。这一直在我的脑海里。我想建一个会所。我有过五六次尝试。我想第六次就是你们发现的那条巨大的隧道。
I've heard him call it the future of clubhouses.
我听过他称之为“会所的未来”。
Again, here's Nick.
再次引用尼克的话。
The treehouse of the future. That it's underground because one of the fundamental things he wanted from this was that it be secret. It was his secret place that he could go and just relax and be alone.
未来的树屋。它在地下，因为他想要的根本东西之一就是它是秘密的。那是他的秘密基地，他可以去那里放松并独处。
Though not always alone. A friend helped Elton dig the tunnel and built it, excavating, he thinks, two dump trucks of dirt by hand. And once it was done, they would go there together, watch movies, listen to music, barbecue.
虽然并不总是独处。一个朋友帮埃尔顿挖了隧道并建造了它，他认为他们手工挖掘了两垃圾车那么多的泥土。一旦完成，他们会一起去那里，看电影、听音乐、烧烤。
OK, I did this because something I always wanted to be doing. But I know I should have grown out of it. And I knew that, OK, if I build a tunnel, it came from childhood reasons. But at the same time, if I build it, who knows? I could probably hang out there, turn that childhood dream into a man cave, a bunker, whatever you call it-- just a place to go hang out. And if there was something that happened, like a natural disaster, or if something were to happen, I could go there-- if there's a blackout-- turn on a generator, charge my phone, even make a small meal down there just to bring back up to my house.
好的，我做这个是因为我一直想做这件事。但我知道我应该长大了。我知道，如果我建一个隧道，那是出于童年的原因。但同时，如果我建了它，谁知道呢？我可能可以去那里待着，把那个童年的梦想变成一个“男人窝”、地堡，不管你叫它什么——只是一个去待着的地方。如果有事发生，比如自然灾害，或者如果发生什么事，我可以去那里——如果停电了——打开发电机，给手机充电，甚至在下面做顿小餐带回我家。
Back when Elton would go to the tunnel, his sisters did not know exactly what he was doing. But they knew something was up. For months, while he was digging the thing, he would come home just covered in dirt, tracking dirt everywhere. Anora thought he was building some kind of underground house and grilled him about it. But he wouldn't say.
当埃尔顿去隧道时，他的姐妹们并不确切知道他在做什么。但她们知道有点不对劲。有几个月，当他在挖那个东西时，他回家时全身都是土，到处都是泥。阿诺拉以为他在建某种地下房屋并盘问他。但他什么都不说。
His other sister, Tracyann, found the rosary actually sitting at a bus stop and gave it to Elton to protect him.
他的另一个姐妹特蕾西安（Tracyann）实际上是在公交站发现念珠的，并把它给了埃尔顿以保佑他。
As soon as she gave it to me, like an hour later, it was already down there. I nailed it up. Every day after that day, every day where I would go there, I would sometimes make a prayer. Not every day-- some days I'd forget. But sometimes I would remember to have a little prayer just so I'm safe. And it's a peace of mind. Yeah.
她刚给我的那一刻，大概一小时后，它就已经在下面了。我把它钉在了墙上。从那天以后的每一天，每一天我去那里，我有时会做个祷告。不是每一天——有些天我会忘记。但有时我会记得做一个小祷告，为了平安。这是一种内心的安宁。是的。
The reality of Elton's tunnel, it was so different from what people thought it was when it was first discovered by police. I think what that's about is, I think when we encounter something that's inexplicable or mysterious, our imaginations-- we are such hacks. You know? We go to the most standard, stock, seen it in 100 TV shows version of what something probably is. Like, oh, it's a terrorist attack. Oh, it's drug dealers. You know?
埃尔顿隧道的现实，与警方刚发现它时人们所想的截然不同。我认为这说明，当我们遇到某种难以解释或神秘的事情时，我们的想象力——我们真是太俗套了。你知道吗？我们总是陷入在100个电视节目中看到的那些最标准、陈旧的猜测里。比如，噢，那是恐怖袭击。噢，那是毒贩。你知道吗？
When the reality of what this tunnel was-- it was this dreamy guy who just wanted a place to get away from his sisters, be alone for a little while. It's so much smaller but so much less predictable and way more interesting.
而这个隧道现实中是什么——它只是一个梦幻般的家伙，想要一个地方远离他的姐妹们，独处一会儿。它小得多，但却不那么好预测，也更有趣得多。
Well, our program was produced today by Bim Adewunmi. People who put our show together today include Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Hillary Elkins, Nora Gill, Damian Grave, Michelle Harris, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editors, Diane Wu and Sarah Abdurrahman. Executive editor, David Kestenbaum.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）制作的。今天参与节目制作的人包括苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、希拉里·埃尔金斯（Hillary Elkins）、诺拉·吉尔（Nora Gill）、达米安·格雷夫（Damian Grave）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、本·费伦（Ben Phelan）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）。我们的执行编辑是戴安·吴（Diane Wu）和萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。执行主编大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。
Special thanks today to Eric Boodman, who first reported on the nurse Elise Barrett for the website Stat, Steve Kolowich, Dr. Christopher Murray and the Institute for Health Metrics and Evaluation, Any Moskovian, Jerel Calaguas, Brendan Geddes, Ava Schreier, and Katie Cederborg.
今天特别感谢埃里克·布德曼（Eric Boodman），他首先为Stat网站报道了护士伊莉丝·巴雷特，感谢史蒂夫·科洛维奇（Steve Kolowich）、克里斯托弗·默里博士（Dr. Christopher Murray）和健康指标与评估研究所（Institute for Health Metrics and Evaluation）、安妮·莫斯科维安（Any Moskovian）、杰雷尔·卡拉瓜斯（Jerel Calaguas）、布伦丹·格迪斯（Brendan Geddes）、艾娃·施莱尔（Ava Schreier）和凯蒂·塞德堡（Katie Cederborg）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org While you're on lockdown or commuting to your essential job, you can listen to our archive of 700 episodes for absolutely free. thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to the public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。当你在禁足或通勤去必需岗位工作时，你可以免费收听我们700集的档案库。thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》通过PRX公共广播交易（Public Radio Exchange）发送给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know the thing he likes to do most while in lockdown? Play Monopoly. But can I say, he is getting so competitive.
一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道他在禁足期间最喜欢做的事情是什么吗？玩大富翁。但我能说吗，他变得太好胜了。
What is there to apologize for, honestly? Yeah, I was an asshole. Yeah, what I did was dishonest. Yeah, it was shady. Yeah, it was insensitive. But I would definitely do it again the exact same way.
有什么好道歉的，说实话？是的，我是个混蛋。是的，我做的是不诚实的。是的，那是阴暗的。是的，那是麻木不仁的。但我绝对会以同样的方式再做一次。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事中。